in this capsule we see some
properties of the tax collector's gallery
firstly the iperceptions jaws
it's an algorithm that will try to
look for a linear separator between
classes be distinguished as
specified so if we are in a space
where the vectors are of size n will say
we are going to look for a hyper plan that will
separate examples are of a class d
other examples are from the other class
so it's easier to visualize
dimensions 2 so imagine we are
two classes that are the points will
the black dots so his industry
associated with class 1 and the other class
zero what a father 70 years of doing is
to find a right that will separate the
two classes so having on one side the
white dots on one side of the black dots
and in fact we can demonstrate that the
parameters vector w in the
collector it's actually to be
the vector perpendicular to the right
who separate who will separate our our two
classes like that and when are we going to talk
of decision area for the father
it's round for a general classification
to talk about the surface that separates
two regions in two classes
different and specifically does that
is going to be the surface that matches point
where we do we are at the limit between the
class 1 and zero class so that's it
we want to tell them by surface
of editing is so a tax collector we're going
see the property that the surface of
decisions associated with the tax collector
it's going to be a surface that's linear
which corresponds to a hyper plus
now what about the algorithm
to train a tax collector so have
to get a model that fits in
observing gives us so is this
algorithm the sino example
are linear
separable so it's possible to do
go in two dimensions a straight that
separate the two classes
this algorithm of the tax collector one is
guaranteed to converge to a solution with
an error we therefore actually a
right that separate our two well
classes on the training set
whatever the choice of the rate
learning alpha ok so in this
that if in fact the choice of both the
more or less important in the sense
are your necessarily finding a
talkie forgiveness a great plan that goes well
separate our classes and the father is found
have a zero error on our
training grounds by cons if we
has data that is not worthy to me
separates mca that no right that allows
or losers that helps separate a
class in 2 so we have an example here where
we would not be able to find
to pass a right that goes well
separate the two classes then in this
case also to obtain a guarantee of
convergence
we will have to make a small
change
so we have a little modification on
will still be able to get a
convergence towards the solution that is the
smallest mistake possible on our
training center and for that in fact
you have to have a learning rate
which vote depends on the number of
day when we made up
now so in fact need
a learning rate that goes down
an iteration then an update
to another is a way to get
relies of having this guarantee is
tired of taking a learning tour
and divide it so that everything
constant learning but we're going
divide by one more
another constant that will determine to
how fast the self learning is going
decrease times khaki the number here that the
number of updates we made
so far starting at m so the
his made his small modifications the
beautiful we will see convergence anyway
towards the best possible solution on
the intention of the training even if
our data are pauline and gives back to his
parents a council that is helpful
to see a little bit of the progression of
learning is what is called
the learning curve simply a
curve that plot either the error rate
or success rate according to preference
so if it's the error rate in section
sap val are there the sooner the
success rate have a curve that is going
increase or close so as
learning a curve that traces the
any success where the error rate in
according to the number of updates of
parameters that we did up to m so
so useful for visualizing progress
of learning and we have three
examples here at first that where we have a
training set that is
linearly separable when we see
is that as and when a certain
oscillations in because if that's the
success rate so their percentage of
well-classified training example
because we see that as we go
measure it improves and eventually
we actually reach 100% of
classification on the intention to
training
then we have a case here where the
data are not linear separate me
and here we do what we observe is that
with a learning rate that
constant what is the case here
so that's the learning cateau
constant we do not really
improvement in the sense that the rate
of error or sorry the success rate does not
do not converge towards a certain value
we always have oscillations but its
teen learning that is decreasing
for example with the formula that I have
shown sometimes where we have a formula where we
divided by a term that depends on the number
updates that we made up
now
but when we look at it we have
a more stable ski-to-ski curve
which quietly offered measure one
made updates will converge
to a straight line to a fixed value of
a correct classification rate and
in this case because it's not dignified
advanced by ramon is not a rate that is
to 1 but that is a little bit below
an Oscar
so we saw the algorithm of the tax collector
have enough to see a little hastily
why what the rule of update
parameters had blood it was a
good update rule for
improve the performance of the tax collector
have been able to better classify our
training data same state is this
what was commenting on what we could
analyze a little better it is she that the
club that actually sees why this is a
good procedure
so there is actually a more
general to develop aghribs
learning still we'll call
the case of minimizing a loss
so actually several of the algorithm
learning will be seen as a
algorithm that tries to minimize a
loss in this case also by fart this
that we mean without a son a kind of
measure of distance between what we have
predicted is what we would like to have
so we see the notte the bone for so in
english losses between yt who is the target
are we lost and in favor of
learning is essentially that
it is that we have some certain costs
are seen or some measure of
performance that is going to be another loss
associated with a predictor h a model
given are you already in fact
is that this model minimizes the most
possible this loss associate it with doing
a prediction for another and x
when the target associated and there is we are going
see made case presenting this problem
there in this general framework there he goes
exist a certain definition of the
loss that will allow us to derivatives
the tax collector's grid just like
algorithms that try to use it
the average loss on our data
training the railing we will have
some reminders of some notions in
differential calculus that will be useful
to approach this problem
optimization there